das kind heißt willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute es ist endlich soweit so
lange habe ich heute gefragt hast du
dich gestört und immer wieder muss ich
sagen nee ist jetzt noch nicht in der
uni und ich habe so viel zu tun
ich habe jetzt sage ich mir zu tun ich
würde es zuvor aber ist es trotzdem
gekommen weil ich geil
4 es ist endlich soweit sollte ich habe
es wieder geschafft für euch einen
merger an den start zu bringen
deswegen steht hier auch wahrscheinlich
auch werbevideo wahrscheinlich okay ja
und die zeit bringen
was jetzt daran besonders ich erzähle
euch dazu die geschichte leute ich habe
mir nämlich bei meinem möglich wieder ab
dass ich gerne etwas machen möchte wozu
ich so eine persönliche verbindung habe
das finde ich generell einfach cooler
wenn man so was raus meinen persönlichen
bezug reinzubringen
dem möchte ich jetzt erklären und wir
natürlich auch zeigen was es gibt denn
wer dort lebt länger wissen was damals
ersten teil und zwar also das ding hat
er wahrscheinlich auch schon den pastor
ist mir gesehen
der schwarze krunic leute mit dem grauen
könnt ihr drauf ist fraglich
wahrscheinlich was ist das hier drauf
ist das kisuaheli und ich weiß es selbst
nicht viel spaß ich weiß nicht dass wir
uns das natürlich ganz klar ist so klein
ist der bis 1995 weil ich geworden bin
in dem jahr aber das hier oben drüber
ist japanisch und dass das japanische
wort für underdog beziehungsweise
japanisches wort mit dem ich dieses
deutsch-englische wo underdog
beschreiben wollte jetzt fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich warum underdogs das ist
ein unterer und nein durchlaufen rund
aber hat und bei denen eheleute das
hatte das hat tatsächlich eine tiefere
bedeutung leute und zwar bezieht sich
das auf meine persönliche vergangenheit
wenn ich heutzutage leuten davon erzähle
wie das damals bei mir sogar sagen wir
die allermeisten so hell was laberst du
das hast du es gerade ausgedacht ist das
kann ich gar nicht sein das würde ich
dir niemals zutrauen aber ich hatte
damals tatsächlich in meiner
teenagerzeit jugend teenager zeit
relativ krasse probleme die komplett
mein leben ruiniert
ich kann nicht ernsthaft ein video und
das ding ist halt wenn man so was in so
einer schlüssel zeit wie der teenager
zeit erlebt trägt man das sein ganzes
leben haben mit sich herum davon bin ich
überzeugt und das ist das prägt einen
jetzt ein guter oder schlechter weise
und deswegen will ich das einfach in den
tag
wenn die ich an euch an meine meine
zuschauer meine fans herausgebe
festhalten ich will es aber auch gar
nicht zu lange um den heißen brei
herumreden die sache war bei mir damals
die das zu dem zeitpunkt wo sich auch
meine eltern getrennt haben mich dann
auch die schule gewechselt habe und zwar
von hessen nach bayern also vom
einfachen hessen das die schule wirklich
einfach nach bayern wo die schule so
viel kraft schwieriger ist und dann kam
einfach dieser zeit so alles auf einmal
natürlich eltern getrennt schulische
probleme kam auch dazu und dann kam noch
dazu und das war somit das schwierigste
in der zeit dass ich einfach und darüber
spreche immer ganz offen weil ich glaube
das ist vielen leuten so geht und dass
viele leute dazu irgendwie bezug
herstellen können hatte ich einfach
relativ kasse probleme damals mit meinen
mitschülern zwar bin ich nach bayern
gekommen und die haben mich in meiner
klasse in bayern von anfang an gemobbt
muss man nichts zu sagen wie sich steht
auch offen zu
meiningen draußen geht es auch um die
können dazu bezug herstellen und das
ging einfach vier jahre lang dass das
halbwegs besser geworden ist und das war
auf jeden fall so die die schwierigste
teil in meinem leben und immer wenn ich
darüber nachdenke was halt nicht selbst
so geprägt meinem leben dann denke ich
immer wieder an diese zeit und wenn ich
jetzt so eine sache wie merger als
persönliches geben möchte dann möchte
ich auf jeden fall diese geschichte dar
einpacken weil das habe ich einfach
geprägt und das trägt man wird ist ein
ganzes leben witzig und deswegen andere
leute weil ich damals war die ganze zeit
der außenseiter war und man ist einfach
immer in seinem kopf drin hat und
mitträgt für dieses gefühl ist schwierig
zu beschreiben heute vielleicht
bestehens ein paar von euch aber einfach
auch zu dieses gefühl dass man nie so
wirklich ganz so weit so das ist wie
gesagt das ist schwierig in worte zu
packen aber das hat mich geprägt und das
bin ich auch heute noch und deswegen
habe ich das in diesem match tie gepackt
und das ist die story hinter diesem
japanischen schriftzug sonja durch das
wisse nicht wie das hier sehen aber ich
hab's rausgehauen verrückt das ist der
hintergrund hinter diesen dingen ja und
da ist das erste teil krunic
schwarzbauer print lange ärmel kurze
haare gesicht komplett scheine in dieser
ganzen kollektion werdet ihr aussehen
gibt es nicht 20.000 designs weil ich
einfach sind behalten möchte ich finde
es aber cool relativ einfache designs
ich habe auch nicht 30.000 verschiedene
tiere ich habe die ganze sache einfach
simpel gehalten weil ich das so geil
finde und man muss ja nicht persönlich
wiedergeben und ich finde das gibt mich
persönlich perfekt wider das erste teil
das design gibt es auch noch als t shirt
leute das sieht dann so aus von hinten
sieht so aus besser wenn mein gesicht
nicht sieht und als wurde gibt es das
ganze auch das heißt wenn man so knapp
wie ich nicht verstecken muss oder wenn
man hat gerne mit rudis tritt kommt das
aufziehen möchte so leuten sehr angenehm
zu tragen und mit einem von denen
übrigens rudi und kollegen sind von ihm
aufgebauten leute das wieder schön mit
dem masterplan wir wollten auch dann
kann ich euch sagen fünfzehnter elfter
18 uhr komplett veröffentlichung
komplett und jetzt heute bevor wir zu
dem zweiten design zu dem limitierten
stück kommen möchte ich mal kurz
erklären wie das ganze abläuft am 15 11
18 uhr werde ich den shop aufmachen und
die ganze sache wird eine woche lang
laufen heißt 22 der fh 18 uhr ist das
zeug dich genau wie letztes jahr dann
würdest du nicht mehr bestellen können
das wird noch nicht wieder geben dann
ist einfach alles weg
das heißt wer die designs haben wollt
15.11.10 18 uhr bis 22 11 18 uhr
das war das erste design deutlich dass
relativ schlicht gehalten damit dass
jeder tragen kann
das zweite ist christel abgebrochen
abgefallene wahrscheinlich leute für das
zweite design das ist dieser kollekte
wird auch nur als projekt geben heißt
kein t shirt kein wunder dass gibt es
nur diese version wie es jetzt daran
habe ich mir einfach gedacht für die
ganze sache bisher ausgefallen da machen
ich möchte ein bisschen runden
lokomotiven das nicht und ich habe mir
einfach gedacht es wäre ultra geiseln
loh in rainbows hin zu machen und dabei
ist dann das hier entstanden ich bin
damit auch ultra zufrieden ich habe den
anderen teil aber ob das dann bin ich
besonders stolz denn ich liebe es von
meinen ganzen ich will aber gar nicht so
lange den heißen brei herum reden leute
letzten endes liegt bei euch ob ich die
sachen gefallen und nicht ob er sagt ok
cool das will ich auch haben oder nicht
das stück wird aber ich denke immer
sogleich 50 maximal 100 mal geben also
das wird dementiert sein weil in anderen
würzen mehr geben das ist quasi die
limited edition die seite das laufen
bedeutet ist genau wie letztes jahr es
so bleibt punkt kommt fünfzehnter elfter
18 uhr bis 22 38 uhr wird die seite
online sein und danach offen danach wird
die sachen nicht mehr
das heißt wenn etwas an bord denn mit
euch und ich bin gespannt weil ich die
sachen gefallen